Hay muchas contradicciones.
Lloramos la muerte trágica
del niño de 2 años, Alan Kurdi,
y, no obstante, desde entonces, más de 200 niños
se ahogaron posteriormente en el Mediterráneo.
Tenemos tratados internacionales
que reconocen que los refugiados son una responsabilidad compartida,
y aun así aceptamos que el pequeño Líbano
albergue más sirios que toda Europa en su conjunto.
Lamentamos la existencia de traficantes de personas,
y aun así hacemos que sea esa la única ruta viable
de buscar asilo en Europa.
Tenemos escasez de mano de obra,
pero si no encajan en nuestras necesidades económicas y demográficas
frenamos el ingreso a Europa.
Proclamamos nuestros valores liberales en oposición al Islam fundamentalista,
pero...
tenemos políticas represivas
que detienen a niños que piden asilo,
que separan a los niños de sus familias,
y que arrebatan propiedades de los refugiados.
¿Qué estamos haciendo?
¿Cómo llegamos a esta situación
de responder de manera tan inhumana a una crisis humanitaria?
No creo que sea porque a las personas no les importe,
o al menos quiero creer que no es así.
Creo que se debe a la falta de visión de nuestros políticos,
una visión de cómo adaptar un sistema internacional de refugiados
creado hace más de 50 años
a un mundo globalizado que cambia.
Por eso quiero detenerme
y hacer dos preguntas fundamentales,
dos preguntas que todos debemos hacernos.
Primero, ¿por qué no funciona el sistema actual?
Y segundo, ¿qué podemos hacer para solucionarlo?
Estos tipos crearon el sistema actual
de refugiados tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Su objetivo fundamental es garantizar
que si un estado falla, o peor aún, si se vuelve contra su pueblo,
las personas tengan a dónde ir,
para vivir con seguridad y dignidad hasta que puedan volver a casa.
Se creó precisamente para situaciones como la que vemos hoy en Siria.
Mediante un convenio internacional firmado por 147 gobiernos,
la Convención de 1951 sobre el Estatuto de los Refugiados,
y una organización internacional, el ACNUR, los estados
se comprometieron recíprocamente a admitir en su territorio
a personas que huyen de conflictos y persecución.
Pero hoy, el sistema está fallando.
En teoría, los refugiados tienen derecho a pedir asilo.
En la práctica, nuestras políticas bloquean el camino a la seguridad.
En teoría, los refugiados tienen derecho a una vía de integración,
o a regresar al país del que vinieron.
En la práctica, quedan atrapados en un limbo casi indefinido.
En teoría, los refugiados son una responsabilidad global compartida.
En la práctica, la geografía implica que los países cercanos al conflicto
albergan la abrumadora mayoría de los refugiados del mundo.
El sistema no colapsó debido a reglas erróneas.
Es que no las aplicamos adecuadamente a un mundo que cambia,
y tenemos que reconsiderarlo.
Por eso quiero explicarles un poco cómo funciona el sistema actual.
¿Cómo funciona el régimen de refugiados?
Pero no desde una perspectiva jerárquica institucional,
sino desde la perspectiva de un refugiado.
Imaginen a una mujer siria.
Llamémosla Amira.
Amira para mí representa a muchas personas que conocí en la zona.
Amira, como un 25 % de los refugiados del mundo,
es una mujer con hijos,
y no puede volver a su hogar porque viene de esta ciudad
que tienen ante Uds., Homs,
una ciudad alguna vez hermosa y con historia,
ahora bajo los escombros.
Por eso Amira no puede regresar.
Pero tampoco tiene esperanza de asentarse en otro país,
porque hay un billete de lotería
solo disponible para menos del 1 % de los refugiados del mundo.
Amira y su familia
enfrentan una opción casi imposible.
Tienen tres opciones.
La primera es que lleve a su familia a un campo.
En el campo, puede que reciba asistencia,
pero hay pocas perspectivas para Amira y su familia.
Los campos están en zonas áridas, desoladas,
a menudo en el desierto.
En el campo de refugiados de Zaatari en Jordania,
pueden oírse las caracolas en la frontera siria por la noche.
Hay actividad económica restringida.
La educación es a menudo de mala calidad.
Y en todo el mundo,
un 80 % de los refugiados que están en campos
tienen que permanecer al menos 5 años.
Es una existencia desdichada,
y quizá por eso, en realidad,
solo el 9 % de los sirios eligen esa opción.
Como alternativa, Amira puede ir a un país vecino,
a una zona urbana, como Amman o Beirut.
Esa es la opción elegida por el 75 % de los refugiados sirios.
Pero también enfrentan grandes dificultades.
Los refugiados en dichas zonas por lo general no pueden trabajar.
Tampoco tienen acceso a asistencia.
Por eso, cuando Amira y su familia hayan agotado sus ahorros,
no les quedará nada, y quizá enfrenten la pobreza urbana.
Hay una tercera alternativa,
y es la opción que gana más adeptos sirios.
Amira puede buscar alguna esperanza para su familia
arriesgando sus vidas en un viaje peligroso
hacia otro país,
y eso es lo que vemos en Europa hoy.
En todo el mundo, le ofrecemos a los refugiados opciones casi imposibles;
deben elegir entre:
campos de refugiados, pobreza urbana, y viajes peligrosos.
Para los refugiados, eso es hoy el régimen global de refugiados.
Pero es una opción falsa.
Pienso que podemos reconsiderar esa opción.
La razón por la que limitamos estas opciones
es porque pensamos
que son las únicas opciones disponibles para los refugiados,
y no es así.
Los políticos abordan el tema como una cuestión de suma cero,
que si beneficiamos a los refugiados, supondrá costos para los ciudadanos.
Solemos suponer en forma colectiva
que los refugiados son un costo o una carga inevitable para la sociedad.
Pero no tiene por qué ser así. Pueden contribuir.
Lo que quiero plantear
es que hay formas de expandir ese repertorio de opciones
y aun así beneficiarnos todos:
los estados anfitriones y las comunidades,
nuestras sociedades y los refugiados.
Y quiero sugerir cuatro formas
de transformar el paradigma de pensar sobre los refugiados.
Las cuatro formas tienen algo en común:
todas son formas de capitalizar las oportunidades de la globalización,
la movilidad y los mercados,
y de actualizar la forma de pensar el tema de los refugiados.
La primera en la que quiero pensar
es la idea de "entornos propicios",
y parte de reconocer algo muy básico
y es que los refugiados son seres humanos, como otros,
solo que atraviesan circunstancias extraordinarias.
Junto con mis colegas de Oxford,
emprendimos una investigación en Uganda,
estudiando la vida económica de los refugiados.
Elegimos Uganda no porque sea representativo de los países anfitriones.
No lo es. Es la excepción.
A diferencia de la mayoría de los otros países,
Uganda les ha dado
oportunidades económicas.
Les da derecho a trabajar. Les da libertad de movimiento.
Y los resultados son extraordinarios
tanto para los refugiados como para el país anfitrión.
En la capital, Kampala,
hallamos que el 21 % de los refugiados tiene un negocio con otro empleado,
y el 40 % de esos empleos
son nativos del país anfitrión.
En otras palabras, los refugiados crean empleos
para los ciudadanos del país anfitrión.
Incluso en los campos, hallamos ejemplos extraordinarios
de negocios vibrantes, florecientes y emprendedores.
Por ejemplo, en un asentamiento llamado Nakivale,
encontramos ejemplos de refugiados congoleños
con negocios de intercambio de música digital.
Encontramos un ruandés que tiene un negocio
de videojuegos para jóvenes
con consolas y TVs reciclados.
Contra todo pronóstico de restricción extrema,
los refugiados innovan,
y el señor congolés que ven allí se llama Demou-Kay.
Demou-Kay llegó al asentamiento con muy poco,
pero quería ser cineasta.
Junto a amigos y colegas creó una radio comunitaria,
alquiló una cámara de video,
y ahora hace películas.
Hizo dos documentales con y para nuestro equipo,
y tiene un negocio exitoso con muy poco.
Es de esos ejemplos
que deberían guiar nuestra respuesta a los refugiados.
En vez de ver a refugiados
dependiendo inevitablemente de la asistencia humanitaria,
hay que darles oportunidades para su florecimiento humano.
Sí, ropa, mantas, refugio, alimentos,
todo eso es importante en etapa de emergencia,
pero tenemos que ver más allá.
Tenemos que dar oportunidades de conectividad, de electricidad,
de educación, de derecho al trabajo,
de acceso al capital y a la banca.
Todas las formas que damos por sentado,
con las que estamos conectados a la economía global,
pueden y deben estar al alcance de los refugiados.
La segunda idea que quiero discutir es la de "zonas económicas".
Por desgracia, no todos los países anfitriones
adoptan el enfoque ugandés.
La mayoría de los países anfitriones no abren sus economías
a los refugiados de igual manera.
Pero hay opciones pragmáticas que podemos usar.
En abril pasado viajé a Jordania con mi colega,
el economista del desarrollo Paul Collier,
y pensamos juntos una idea mientras estuvimos allí
con la comunidad internacional y el gobierno,
una idea para dar empleo a los sirios
y a la vez apoyar la estrategia de desarrollo nacional jordana.
Es la idea de una zona económica,
en la que potencialmente se pueda integrar el empleo de los refugiados
con el empleo de los anfitriones jordanos.
Y a solo 15 minutos del campo de refugiados de Zaatari,
hogar de 83 000 refugiados,
hay una zona económica
llamada Área de Desarrollo Rey Hussein Bin Talal.
El gobierno ha gastado más de USD 100 millones
para conectarlo a la grilla eléctrica, a la red de carreteras,
pero le falta dos cosas:
acceso al trabajo y a la inversión interna.
¿Y si los refugiados pudiesen trabajar allí
en vez de quedar atrapados en los campos,
y pudiesen ayudar a sus familias y formarse profesionalmente
antes de volver a Siria?
Reconocimos que eso podría beneficiar a Jordania,
cuya estrategia de desarrollo requiere dar el salto
de país de ingresos medios a país productor.
Podría beneficiar a los refugiados pero podría contribuir también
a la reconstrucción de Siria luego del conflicto
el reconocer que necesitamos incubar refugiados
como la mejor fuente para, al final, reconstruir Siria.
Publicamos la idea en la revista Foreign Affairs.
El rey Abdullah la tomó.
Se anunció en la Conferencia Siria de Londres hace dos semanas,
y comenzará un piloto en el verano.
(Aplausos)
La tercera idea que quiero presentarles
es la de "preferencia concordante" entre estados y refugiados
para producir los resultados felices que vemos en la selfie
de Angela Merkel y los refugiados sirios.
Rara vez preguntamos a los refugiados qué quieren, dónde quieren ir,
pero planteo que podemos preguntarles
y hacer que todos estemos mejor.
El economista Alvin Roth ha desarrollado la idea de mercado concordante,
donde las preferencias de las partes modelan una concordancia consiguiente.
Mis colegas Will Jones y Alex Teytelboym
han explorado formas de aplicar esa idea a los refugiados,
para pedirles que indiquen sus destinos preferidos,
pero que le permita a los estados indicar los refugiados que quieren
según sus habilidades, sus idiomas,
y permitir esa concordancia.
Pero, claro, se necesitan cuotas
en temas como diversidad y vulnerabilidad,
pero es una forma de aumentar las posibilidades de concordancia.
La idea de concordancia se ha empleado con éxito
para encontrar afinidad, por ejemplo, de estudiantes con universidades,
afinidad entre donantes renales y pacientes,
y subyace en los algoritmos existentes de los sitios web de citas.
¿Por qué no aplicar eso para darles más opciones a los refugiados?
Podría usarse también a nivel nacional,
donde uno de los grandes desafíos que enfrentamos
es convencer a las comunidades locales para que acepten refugiados.
Por el momento en mi país, por ejemplo,
a menudo enviamos ingenieros a zonas rurales y granjeros a las ciudades,
algo que no tiene sentido.
Los mercados concordantes tienen potencial para unir esas preferencias
y atender las necesidades y demandas de las poblaciones anfitrionas
y de los propios refugiados.
La cuarta idea que quiero proponerles es la de "visas humanitarias".
Mucha de la tragedia y el caos que hemos visto en Europa
era totalmente evitable.
Radica en una contradicción elemental de las políticas de asilo europeas,
y es la siguiente:
que para buscar asilo en Europa,
uno tiene que llegar de manera espontánea embarcado en esos viajes peligrosos
que describí.
Pero ¿por qué hacer eso en una era de vuelos económicos
y capacidades consulares modernas?
Son viajes totalmente innecesarios,
y el año pasado causaron la muerte de más de 3000 personas
en las fronteras de Europa y dentro del territorio europeo.
Con tan solo permitirles
viajar directamente y buscar asilo en Europa,
evitaríamos eso,
y hay una manera de hacerlo
mediante algo llamado visa humanitaria,
que le permite a las personas pedir una visa en una embajada
o en el consulado de un país vecino
y pagarse el viaje
en ferry o en un vuelo a Europa.
Cuesta alrededor de 1000 euros
llevar un contrabandista de Turquía a las islas griegas.
Cuesta 200 euros ir en una aerolínea económica de Bodrum a Frankfurt.
Permitir eso a los refugiados, tendría más ventajas.
Salvaría vidas,
debilitaría el mercado del contrabando,
y eliminiaría el caos que vemos en la primera línea de Europa
en zonas como las islas griegas.
La política impide que hagamos eso y no una solución racional.
Y es una idea que ya se ha aplicado.
Brasil adoptó un enfoque pionero
en el que 2000 sirios consiguieron visas humanitarias;
entraron a Brasil, y pidieron estatus de refugiados al llegar al país.
Bajo ese esquema, todo sirio que lo solicitó
recibió estatus de refugiado y fue reconocido como refugiado genuino.
Hay un precedente histórico también.
Entre 1922 y 1942,
estos pasaportes Nansen se usaron como documentos de viaje
para permitir que 450 000 asirios, turcos y chechenos,
viajaran por Europa
y solicitaran estado de refugiados en el resto de Europa.
Y la Oficina Internacional de Refugiados Nansen
recibió el Premio Nobel de la Paz
en reconocimiento a esto como estrategia viable.
Las cuatro ideas que les he presentado
son maneras de ampliar el repertorio de opciones de Amira.
Son formas en las que podemos dar más opciones a los refugiados,
más allá de esas tres opciones elementales imposibles
que les expliqué
e incluso dejar a otros en mejor situación.
En conclusión, realmente necesitamos una nueva visión,
una visión que amplíe las opciones de los refugiados
y reconozca que no tienen por qué ser una carga.
No es inevitable que los refugiados sean un costo.
Sí, son una responsabilidad humanitaria,
pero son seres humanos con habilidades, talentos, aspiraciones,
que pueden contribuir, si los dejamos.
En el nuevo mundo,
la migración no va a desaparecer.
Lo que vemos en Europa, perdurará entre nosotros durante años.
Las personas seguirán viajando,
seguirán siendo desplazadas,
y tenemos que encontrar formas racionales y realistas de manejarlo;
no con base en la vieja lógica de la asistencia humanitaria;
no con base en la lógica de la caridad,
sino construyendo oportunidades
que ofrece la globalización, los mercados y la movilidad.
Los animo a despertar y a instar a nuestros políticos
a que despierten ante este desafío.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)